let's talk about anger
and pain in america no justice
my black brothers and sisters are being
shot being killed
for no reason i am tired
by now we all know what happened george
floyd an unarmed black man
died after a white police officer
kneeled on his neck
for more than eight minutes
we've been here before many many times
[Applause]
black people are saying enough is enough
and so this is a crunch
moment and an opportunity for real
change
so how did we get here what's behind
that feeling of injustice
why are so many black americans being
killed by police
what has to change to make it stop
[Music]
[Applause]
this is about a lot more than one man's
death
or the deaths of so many other unarmed
black people before george floyd
for the people protesting this is about
what it means to be black
in america when i ran for president of
my school
somebody hung a noose during black
history month at my university
that's what it's like to be black in
america anytime i have an encounter with
a police officer
i'm on edge if your name is keon
or tarsha andre or dante you're less
likely to get caught
for a job the fact is that america today
in 2020 is more segregated than it was
when i was a kid
and that says something there were
things that i will do
that the american dream which is a false
dream
tells me that i am entitled to and then
in all the forces
someone will try to stop me that's what
it's like to be black in america
the roots of that inequality run deep
slavery has been outlawed in america for
more than 150 years
but that didn't give black people equal
opportunities or rights
and it didn't end the terror between
1877 and 1950
there were more than four thousand
lynchings we are bored with the harm
we are born with injustice we cannot
take this any longer
racial segregation was only outlawed in
1964.
black americans were only guaranteed the
right to vote a year later
being black came at a price then
and activists say it still does today
black men and women who finish college
make less than a white person
who goes to high school economically
they are disproportionately
unemployed by health insurance the lack
of debt
the country was founded on slavery in
the genocide of native americans was
founded on the oppression of women
donald trump is actually not the problem
the problem is
bigger than him it's the systemic
oppression and marginalization of
different types of people of course
history including black people
white supremacy is not the shark it's
the water
if we think it's the shark then it's
enough to just arrest and charge the
officers and we're done here we can all
go home
but it's the very water that we're
swimming in it informs every part of our
life and then you look at the numbers
black americans are a minority just 13
of the population but in prison they
make up 33
of all the inmates and if you're an
unarmed black civilian
you're more than twice as likely as a
white person to be killed
and police violence against black
americans well that happens a lot
rodney king was unarmed when he was
beaten by la police and left with brain
damage
tamir rice was playing with a toy gun in
cleveland when he was shot by a police
officer
30 meters away tamir was 12 when he died
and brianna taylor shot nine times
inside her own home in louisville
by police executing a search warrant
it's like
watching a bad movie over and over again
and i think
you hear that deep sense of desperation
and it's not just the police doing the
killing
trayvon martin was 17 unarmed and killed
by george zimmerman
a neighborhood watch coordinator in
florida we the jury find george
zimmerman not guilty it may be your
child
the backlash to zimmerman's acquittal
gave rise to black lives matter
no justice no justice
ahmed arbury was out jogging in georgia
when he was killed
three white men have been charged people
are tired they're tired of the brutality
against black people the countless
murders of black people so why does it
keep happening
why do so many black people feel that
law enforcement and the justice system
are failing them let's look at the
broken window theory
it was embraced by some police forces in
the 90s and the idea is that if you
crack down on the small things
you prevent bigger crimes now there are
lots of studies that question whether it
actually works
but what we do know is that it's led to
more policing of poor neighborhoods
more police confrontations with
minorities more stopping
frisking and arrests of black people for
things like graffiti
petty theft and drugs i'm talking
white and black cops and asian cops
dehumanize black people in poor areas
it's embedded in them that black people
are inherently bad
that doesn't start with police stations
it starts
with decades and decades of policies
that have created
ghettos that have created low-income
communities which require people
to look for other sources of income and
support their family which is why they
live in the condition and that they're
in
and then there's the practice of sending
officers to police communities they're
not from
the of police officers in baltimore live
far away some as far as pennsylvania the
first time they need a black person is
when
they get a badge and a license to take
their freedom
or their lives no one though is saying
policing isn't tough
the issue is that there's a line between
keeping officers safe
and the abuse of power they're often
trained to react quickly
maybe with force in a profession where
we can literally
have just seconds to survive we must
eliminate any obstacle that could get in
the way
of our reaction to an attack the rights
activists say
it can be hard to hold officers
accountable for lots of reasons
police departments often investigate
their own when there's a complaint
what if you did something wrong and if
your best friend at work
was the person that had to hand down the
punishment they probably wouldn't hand
down that severe
of a punishment right that's kind of how
these departments work
even if a case goes to trial the law
says use of force must be judged from
the perspective of a reasonable officer
they all end up saying the same thing i
fear for my life like you hear this over
and over again
but you shot that guy eight times in in
the back you fed for your life
because he was running away from you
according to one advocacy group
only one percent of all killings by
police ever lead to an officer being
charged with a crime
that's charged not convicted here's some
more names
nypd officer daniel pantaleo put eric
garner in a chokehold that killed him
i can't breathe i can't breathe
he was never convicted of a crime but he
was fired five years later
police officer darren wilson shot and
killed 18 year old michael brown in
ferguson missouri
he was eventually cleared of criminal
charges
you threatened to drag me out of my own
car get out of the car
and then i will light you up get out wow
now
it's why so many black americans have
been using their phones
to keep a record of what happened
what we really want at the end of the
day is to feel safe in our communities
and to be protected
and so it is not a all cops are bad
there's a list of police officers that
are still off the hook
and that culture and policing is bad in
the case of george floyd
several people recorded the actions of
those four police officers
it took a while but all four were fired
and charged
winning a conviction will be hard let me
be honest here i mean our country has
under prosecuted these matters
in minnesota and throughout the country
so what is the way forward
well many advocates are pushing for
reforms like getting the police to keep
a record of when they threaten civilians
with a gun
we have blood we bleed we have biases
and i think all of us need to continue
to see each other
continue to hear each other continue to
work together
but change has been slow we've tried to
reform the police department
and those measures thus far have not
worked
we need a true transition in the united
states and that requires
a very very deep fundamental change
not just reform now is the time to plot
plan strategize and mobilize
it's what colin kaepernick was trying to
say when he took a knee
it was a peaceful protest during the
national anthem and he was blacklisted
for it
you know what colin kaepernick did was
to defy
a very white institution and to say i'm
not going to perform for you anymore if
you treat
people who look like me in this way four
years later
people are still protesting and people
are still dying
and right now there's a lot going on in
america every so often there's a new
video circulating online of white people
calling the police on black people
in this one a woman calls 9-1-1 for
being told to follow
park rules and put her dog on a leash
i'm going to tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like and
it's all coming to a head during a
pandemic
where report after report points out
that more black americans are dying from
the virus
because of things like unequal access to
health healthcare and poverty
so many people are looking for
leadership from the very top
but president donald trump well he has
plenty of critics who say he's only
making things worse
we have a president now who has ensued
the violence
by tweeting the agitation he has not
shown any interest
in using messages of reconciliation or
unity
but they're not just appealing to the
president we don't have the privilege
to be even able to dismantle the system
it should be
why people who are saying this isn't
right it takes a whole lot of work
to be able to understand that your place
in society
is connected to your privilege even
though you didn't ask for it we need
more leaders to have the courage to do
that work because then
it changes the system culture where
everyone can say oh if they're able to
do it
then i can do the work within myself too
some people are hopeful
and they're determined to make something
of this moment because families can't
get back what they've lost
he will never see her grow up
graduate he will never walk
down the aisle i'm here for my baby
and i'm here for george because i want
justice for him there's a lot going on
here
we've barely scratched the surface but
the message from protesters has been
no justice no peace justice and peace
that's the future they want for
themselves and for america
to ease some of that pain centuries of
it
[Music]
that was just a primer it's what we do
on start here
but there's of course a lot more to this
story the george floyd case
violence at the protests and of course
the politics but we're following all of
those angles on aljazeera.com and
on our social media pages so make sure
to follow like and subscribe
i'll see you next week